was talking about performance inspiring
a few minutes ago just to know that he
and other guys that are coming up are
inspired by you and what you're doing I
guess what does what does that mean to
you uh what you mean Wy called your in
his PO he said that your performance is
inspiring for him to to witness that and
to be part of that I guess to know that
you're having that impact on the guys
coming up what is what that is great uh
because um man I even though I saw it
playing late you know from the time I
started playing Kobe was my guy uh he's
the reason why I started playing
basketball and it's funny because on the
same night he had 81 and you know um you
know that was my favorite player so know
when I started I was the guys that I was
looking you know I was looking up to and
you know that they were doing all this
so you know if he says it's inspiring I
hope you know in a couple years uh
hopefully when I'm I don't have to guard
him and I'm out of the league he he's
able to do the same thing and you know
go out and break all his record and
possibly break wilt's record of 100
points if he inspire you you know you
have a you have a knack for coming up
with big games and big moments and the
eyes of the league were sort of on you
and him tonight no I I I wouldn't say
that because um just like I mentioned
the other night against Denver uh it's
not like I just woke up one day and I
was like okay I got to try to go out and
dominate and have the best game of my
career um you know I try to do it every
single night on both ends of the floor
um you know that's where the mindset
just trying to go out and dominate uh so
yeah there you know I'm I'm really just
you know pushing myself and challenging
myself every single night um you know
what else canot do what else can I add
to my game uh you know can I try
something new uh to see if it work so if
it doesn't so yeah I'm just really
challenging
myself